faciliter la mobilisation et augmenter
les effectifs de l'armée l'Ukraine tente
de renflouer ses rangs l'étatmajor et
les ministres du gouvernement sont
d'accord sur la nécessité d'augmenter
les effectifs des soldats mais la mesure
divise le pays épuisé par la
guerre je peux certainement vous dire
que nous n'avons pas assez de monde dans
l'armée je ne pense pas que mobiliser
davantage de personnes soit suffisant
nous avons besoin du soutien de
l'Occident des États-Unis nos soldats
seul ne suff
pas depuis des mois le chef d'état-major
Valéri zalouni et le président volodimir
Zelinski se renvoie la balle sur cette
épineuse question de la mobilisation
lundi le gouvernement a mis sur la table
un projet de loi dont la principale
mesure consiste à abaisser l'âge de
l'enrolllement des soldats à 25 ans au
lieu de 27 actuellement volodimir
zelensk affirme que le chef d'état-major
lui a demandé de recruter près de 500000
soldats Valérie zalouen lui dément avoir
donné un chiffre mais critique néanmoins
le processus actuel de
recrutement pour être franc pour
l'instant je ne suis pas satisfait du
travail des bureaux de recrutement si
j'étais satisfait de leur travail nous
ne serions pas en train de discuter de
ce projet de
loi malgré les nombreux volontaires au
début de la guerre les lamp patriotiques
s souffle et les stratégies pour éviter
la mobilisation se multipli certains fui
le pays falsifi des médicaux pour se
déclarer inapte à la guerre ou sous
doigt des responsables de
circonscription militaire ses absents et
la difficulté sur le terrain ont poussé
le gouvernement à durcir le ton avec ce
projet de loi qui pourrait encore être
amendé mais le président Zelenski semble
ne pas totalement assumer ce projet
déposé au Parlement par ses ministres
s'il se tient loin des discussions son
chef d'état-major s'est dit lui ouvert à
une démobilisation des militaires après
36 mois de service sans interruption